oh man oh oh man we spent approximately
three months of research and development
to get this
it takes a hearty like yeah on his head
let Mark go to the ground they put me
out they're like okay roll over and I'm
like wait I I'm stuck to the ground
boom Oh that's a hard slam so trick
trick to that slime
thanks to Bessie for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
find out more about Bessie's Black
Friday sale
foreign
[Music]
happy Saturday I'm on the couch Nico's
on the couch so you know it's another
episode of stuntman reacts and we have
the amazing legendary Sun performer Mark
Wagner
yes a little shimmy a little wave I
guess I'm a legendary professional
whatever words you just called me right
right yeah yeah been doing this for a
while worked on a lot of Marvel movies
did a few Pirates of the Caribbean
movies did the first Spider-Man movie
grew up as a gymnast acrobat and now I'm
trying to just keep it going you are
keeping it going that's for sure we have
a bunch of really great clips from
Pirates of the Caribbean to Marvel to a
whole bunch of surprises here so let's
just jump right in and surprises
foreign
do you think this wise boy what did you
work on in this film uh I was Orlando
Bloom's stunt double for this film oh
cool we spent a good amount of that time
with the legendary Bob Anderson who if
you look him up you go back he was a
double for Darth Vader oh wow and so he
came in with all of this sword knowledge
this guy didn't have any at that time
this guy learned in six weeks all of
this sword fight skill and Bob Anderson
was the master
so what's really cool about this piece
too is they actually hooked these swords
up to cables so that when they touched
they would spark so I had these cables
running down my leg and Johnny had these
cables running down his leg and it would
be like spark spark spark every one of
those kids so I'm watching this I feel
like I'm seeing the actors the whole
time it is for the most part you know
our goal is stunt doubles obviously is
to get the actors to do most of it
unless it's just so difficult or they're
just struggling with something then
they'll throw us and have us do it a lot
of times we'll do a master shot we'll
come in and just do the whole big shot
and then they'll plug in the actors to
get their faces in it what have they
done to your face to make you look like
Orlando Bloom just make up and dirtied
me up a little bit I grew the facial
hair to match they trim it to match they
did put extensions in my hair I have
full extensions in my hair for like six
months
this is where we really get into it yeah
[Laughter]
so most of the time like when it's
looking at Johnny Depp and we're seeing
like over Orlando Bloom's shoulder in
the sword fight is happening is that
usually you that's in those shots yes
for all of this it would be either over
my shoulder to Johnny or over Tony
angelotti's shoulder to Orlando there's
a part here where he steps on this board
and I misjudged how far away it was
going to be and it actually hit me in
the face oh man my counterpart Tony
angelotti steps on the plank hits me in
the face I Fall to my butt started
bleeding and he's like oh my God
I'm like it's fine everything's fine oh
God it's not fine
it's okay it's just a oh
actually my favorite part when we were
up in the rafters because we had these
two planks they look narrow but they're
probably about 10 or 12 inches wide but
it looks kind of sketch right are you
guys just on the planks we're not on the
planks no safety oh but I mean they're
walls next to us so if I lost my balance
I could just touch the wall or touch the
beam and right and not fall
that was like when I was a kid you do
the cherry drop off of the bars at
school I just did that and they're like
we love it I'm like are you kidding me
that's like a childhood move
so we're in Pirate Vibe so we're going
to go to yeah
yes yes we're a Pirates of Caribbean too
and this is one of my favorite fights
he's actually uh it's on the big wheel
is it it's a three-way fight
[Music]
so you were Orlando Bloom's double again
for this yes Tony angelotti was Jack
Sparrow Thomas Dupont was our Jack
Davenport doubles and that's all real
we're really on top of this building and
that's about 12 to 14 inches wide those
things that we're standing on did you
fall at all um I didn't no smart Wagner
I am human
every foot placement was measured out we
knew right where we were stepping and
then Johnny comes in and it all changes
yeah
sure he's here he's going to make us
laugh yes we had safety cables in case
we fell but if we fell it was it was
like a setup to get us
because camera is really low and that's
up on a hill so it looks a lot higher
than it is that being said it's high you
would get hurt if you fell right but it
looks a lot higher than it is
I'm assuming you guys are using aircraft
aluminum swords yes they're fairly
lightweight and we were constantly
sanding them down because every little
thing they get next and then if that
touches your skin it's a cut they are
light and they are safe they're not
sharp but when you're hitting them
against other metal objects they get
sharp real quick so we were constantly
having to file them down this shot where
it turns is CG all the rest of it is
real this right here is the CG until it
goes over him and then all of this is
real wow
we spent approximately three months of
research and development to get this we
had two wheels two different setups one
was on cables it was being pulled and
one was behind a truck so it could be
kind of maneuvered a little easier any
safety wires or anything like that or
just don't screw up yeah when we're on
top of the wheel there's a high line
that goes across the whole length of the
wheel and so we had a little bit of
Bungee in our rig so it wasn't taking
our weight but if we misstep it could
kind of pull us back on track and then
we are fighting up their actual sword
fights with actual swords it's all real
but we only had six moves and we were
just looping six moves in different
different variations so that we can make
it look like it was all something new
but it took our mind off of okay we have
to focus on choreography to focus on hey
I don't want to fall off this 18 foot
tall wheel that I'm running backwards on
that was another thing I ran backwards
the whole time
and then we get inside so when we first
started testing this they had this
sitting off of the ground on like a
spinning just in their special effects
warehouse and we're like what can we do
this so this is kind of this stuff we
started to work out very early on was
what we could do inside of it and then
they tie us in and start spinning and
start rolling it so now we're just like
yeah it's like a washing machine kind of
but then you're like I hope I don't puke
right I was gonna ask that did anybody
get sick
um I don't believe so no there was one
day I got really overheated but nobody
ever really like threw up motion
sickness kind of thing you know you hear
about a sub performer as a stunt double
being brought onto multiple films or
kind of being like paired with an actor
and they'd stay with that actor [ __ ] say
does like an actor have like is it
Orlando Bloom being like yo I want mark
on Pirates of the Caribbean too because
he was with me on one or is that the
producers that are making that call
sometimes an actor will request his
double sometimes it'll come from the
producer but for the most part it comes
from the stock coordinator I was
fortunate to do five films with Orlando
Bloom and it was because I kind of knew
the coordinators and they reached out to
me but he never really requested me he
did recently but um first time I'd
worked with him was on the first Pirates
and honestly he was a little skeptical
because he's like I should be doing all
this stuff and I'm like hey bro I'm just
I'm just here to help just here to make
you look good and then it was after that
we were working on Kingdom of Heaven and
he pulled me aside and said hey I got to
see a rough cutter the movie they go how
did it look he goes I have to say thank
you because you made me look really good
and I was like oh not what I was
expecting to hear but thanks
awesome that's really you know I was
expecting to be like oh something
something you know but he gave me a
really nice compliment and I said hey
that's why I'm here that's why I do what
I do
so my parents were here this day I got
to bring my parents
wow
so how much of this is you it's you
doing the big swing as soon as he takes
off the feet this is all me well that's
totally my face
all the feet and then the slam boom boom
Oh that's a hard slam so trick trick to
that slime there's an inch of insulate
foam on that wall and we had an artist
paint that whole thing on top of foam
and then put that foam onto the wall so
that I could just face plant right into
it but if you look really closely you
can see my knee kind of makes it Buckle
a little bit Yeah they move the crane in
so that it would stop right at the wall
yeah and then I stood just holding on I
didn't have a harness on for this I was
just holding on I had to slam and then
drop how many times did you have to do
that shot or they're like the first one
they're like it's good at least three or
four times because I remember I'd have
to unhook climb down run around to the
other building climb back up and on the
way I'd pass my parents and they're like
good job
when he saves MJ a lot of that was all
problems
yeah so this is all real swinging right
here they shot in Palos Verdes there's
an old Marine World or one of those kind
of things on the edge of a cliff so they
use the The Horizon as a blue screen oh
cool and so we shot all of these big
swings not all of them a lot of these
big swings in that spot and then they
would just plug it into this plate shot
in the backgrounds of New York what's
something about swinging like Spider-Man
that you wouldn't expect the g-forces
yeah the g-force is for sure at the
bottom of the Swing some of the swings
we had a crane up at like 190 feet so I
would go from about 90 or 100 feet and
just drop into a swing and you get to
the bottom of that swing there can you
pull upside down I'm like
it's really hard
so it's like all this core strength just
to you know mind you I'm cabled in I'm a
harnessed in so I'm not going to fall
but to pull a different position at the
bottom of that swing is so difficult and
like keeping your legs up my magic it's
really hard
were you sore afterwards a lot of the
times yeah well I was sore because I'm
in a spandex suit so there's no room for
padding underneath a harness so even the
padding that's built into harnesses I
was straps on skin so I had gnarly
calluses and bruises just from trying to
hide these harnesses under spandex this
is a tension-based suit so it only
worked as a whole meaning that the whole
suit had to be on you couldn't have half
a suit it wouldn't stretch or feel the
same and it had zippers in the back so
once you're in it you're in it but it
had to be so specifically placed because
if the hole was cut for a harness in the
wrong spot it would move right a piece
of the suit and the suit was 3D printed
as well as a muscle suit attached
underneath so the 3D printing gave it
more definition than it actually had
something that I became very aware of is
that the suit is definitely going
through r d while it's being shown to
everybody in the movie right and the
First costume is always kind of a
prototype and just to let everybody know
Mark has been multiple superheroes in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe one of
them is the amazing Ant-Man
[Music]
I threw this guy through the glass yes
technically he's on wires and I'm just
faking throw him through the glass but
he got a big Shard of glass in his
foreign
and I felt like I did that to him so I
had all these feelings of God I'm so
horrible I can't believe I just did this
to another human being when technically
I didn't really do it I was just faking
the motion and making it look like it
threw him he takes it hard and he like
yeah on his head and the Char just went
right into his forehead that's a one
take kind of shot yeah they got it in
one it looks great it does I've seen you
in some of the craziest costumes with it
man how has the evolution gone with
allowing you to perform better more
comfortability more breathability so on
and so forth so the first Ant-Man suit I
remember like not being able to even
raise my arms up to the height of my
shoulder it was like it was so stiff
right we could run and that's most see
what he does there's a lot of running so
that was fine but but raising your arms
up to do any kind of flipping movement
or any of that was like
so then it became motion capture or it
became putting on the gray suit doing it
to get the movement and then they would
put the character on top of that how
often was the suit breaking so they have
this stuff called butyl but I learned
what butyl was it's like a gluey clay
sticky stuff and each time a piece would
break they just more beautiful put the
butyl on and like tack it back together
okay let's go I'm assuming every couple
shots so like a piece would like it
depends if I was bumping into things or
falling down or stuff yes but this one
held up really well it was a tank this
suit which why it was so hard to move in
when the costume is on completely is
that Paul Rudd in it very often or do
they almost always throw in a stunt
person
[Music]
[Laughter]
honestly if there's a helmet on it's
probably a stunt person for sure in
Civil War we had Paul three days three
days we shot for three months and he had
a fourth day for ADR everything was
helmet on so it was all me and I was the
only double Ant-Man double on that one
which I thought was actually really cool
too because Paul wasn't there for this
so it's right it's me and five amazing
level characters and and the actors it
is all stuntmen and Scarlett Johansson
yeah
it's all because of the faces you can
see their faces you can't see their
faces it's interesting how hyper
efficient that is where it's like look
if you can't see their face we're using
one of the other people that plays the
costume it's like we're only gonna have
the actor who can see the face all right
Lang
guys
so this is a really cool shot because
it's kind of ant-man's introduction into
this sequence and he gets to hand The
Shield to cap so it's actually kind of
iconic for me too because I used to play
Spider-Man and now I'm playing Ant-Man
and I'm I'm taking the shield from my
old mean giving it to my new boss
I actually just thought about that
that's really cool
the best shot when we all come together
oh this is so fun so this is the second
rendition of the Ant-Man suit the knees
didn't Flex they're like you gotta run
and I was like uh Christ these knees
don't bend how am I supposed to even
walk so they're like oh it'll be fine I
go okay I run I come right back and both
knees were split and I was like yeah so
about those knees I was telling you
well they're fine now but so the costume
the upper part of this was in two pieces
so the arms were separate from the
costume so I could actually raise my
arms above my head in this costume and
that was very different from the first
one and then I run in here and get
kicked and then nuts by Scarlett
Johansson best day of my life
thank you
[Music]
why does it say 38 not 40. because your
mom wants to be 38 let's not mention it
again this is 40 it was the the first
time that I had worked with him some
anybody who rides bikes is like that's
their biggest fear someone's not paying
attention and they open their car door
well I had to do that
oh man oh man mind you I'm wearing
shorts short sleeve shirt so no elbow
pads no knee pads so as soon as I'm
upside down Clips are already off they
blew the glass window timing was pretty
perfect right and then I'd go play I'm
right to my shoulder and hip you do that
way more gracefully than I could have
imagined the thing all I was really
thinking here was grab the front brake
and talk your head as long as my head's
in a safe position like the rest of my
body can flop around it the door if you
notice it it's open flat so it is open
farther than what a normal car door
would open they put a piece of kind of
canvas that stretched a little bit so it
actually gave the door a little bit of
flex you see when I hit it it flexes yep
that helped me a lot right takes a
little bit of the impact but the impact
from the door I was less worried about
then they came back from the ground I'm
just really impressed by how you broke
down this moment it's like okay so you
need to hit a car door and you're like
how can I do this in a way that looks
like a hard crash not hiding anything on
cameras right there but at the same time
there is control and it's that plan of
locking up the front brakes you're
initiating that that tuck yeah as you go
into it and if I were to pull the brake
too soon I wouldn't have even made it to
the door maybe I would have gone over
and my foot would have hit the door so
there's it's all that timing too and you
can see that where the tire is it's kind
of right before the door and then it
just I crank it and it lifts me right
off so they were watching this in slow
motion and you guys can probably see it
now they were questioning the timing of
the glass blowing up and they were
thinking it was slightly off watch it
cracks right before my butt see to me it
makes sense that a crack in your helmet
hits it but you won't no one knows that
no one will notice that you'll think oh
my God yes the helmet something hits it
but it it cracks slightly before me but
you add the sound you'll never know
you're watching it at regular speed
you'll never know so I almost had to do
it again and I'm sitting there on the
curb like this like please please no
please you know but they they were happy
with it so
your friend sauerkraut
so I'm one of the guys in the center of
the table with my back to Leo okay so I
don't get to see it coming other than
the reaction of the people across from
me we had full hoods so that everything
is fully covered all skin is protected
and then we had a little straw to
breathe out of so right before we shoot
we pull the straw we hold our breath
we're now holding our breath for the
entire length of this time that we're on
fire and we have to actually hold our
breath until they put us out because the
CO2 that comes in and puts the fire out
you can't breathe it there's no Oxygen
so you actually have to hold your breath
for longer so we're holding our breath
approximately 30 seconds maybe a minute
at most for this sequence and we did
this three times the first time because
Leo was a bit nervous with the
flamethrower he was going really fast so
it didn't light underneath the table so
the second time you went too slow and on
that one he stopped on me and Travis all
I see is orange and I'm like what's
happening what's happening
I'm getting really warm and they're like
oh yeah stop stop you know I get to hear
everybody yelling like Mark go to the
ground they put me out and they're like
okay roll over and I'm like wait I I'm
stuck to the ground so my costume had
melted and I was stuck to the ground and
I couldn't roll over I finally peeled
and rolled over and I just said to the
guys hey everybody I'm really hot get
everything off of me right now and they
pulled all my clothes off his minus my
underwear oh my clothes off as fast as
they could and I had a little burn on my
arm oh really a little just like a
little second degree blister and I was
like yep I felt that they're like are
you okay to do it one more time I'm like
yes we're doing this today you gotta get
this right so the third time I put on
another layer so I actually had three
layers on bottom three layers on top
three layers on my hood and I didn't
feel a thing a third time and you can
see look at it's so much fire yeah yeah
the thing is with full Fire Burns is
there's a lot of prep that goes into it
it's not just hey let's pour some gas on
this guy and light them on fire no there
are layers and layers and layers that go
into this from choreography to what we
have on to the type of protective gel
that's on the clothing that's on our
skin there's eight of us being burned
here on camera but there's 18 fire
safety people each person had dedicated
two people on them if anything were to
go wrong I just dropped down and one of
the or both of those two people come
over to me and assess the situation so
this plane throwers put out a ton of
heat too it's like outside just oh
you're lit on Fires like you're also
engulfed in that Inferno and so you look
at where Leo is standing and he did all
of these he had a double but he was in
all of this the heat all comes up so
it's even hotter where he is than where
we are right you see really win back as
the jackets going and the heat gets up
there I'm always extremely impressed by
the amount of engineering that goes into
each moment and I feel like a lot of
people their perception of stunts is
that it's Daredevils right it's Evil
Knievel but in my experience for film
there's a certain element of risk
yeah it's engineering it's problem
solving it's still performance we take
risks but they're calculated risk
calculate Risk Takers that's what I was
told by Holland d as a desperate stem
people are calculated Risk Takers yeah
we're not Daredevils we're not Evil
Knievel jumping The Fountains at
Caesar's Palace right just because
no we're often given a story and said
hey can you achieve this and it's like
yes how can we achieve this with taking
the minimal risks I love fire stunts
worse than the movies the coolest fire
Stones please leave some comments down
below for some suggestions for us to
check out hey guys Jordan here the
holidays are coming up and you're going
to be traveling you're going to be
getting gifts but guess what today's
sponsor Vesti we've got you covered I
don't know what you have planned whether
you're going to be boating down in
Florida or skiing up in Utah with your
family but instead of packing five
different pairs of shoes in your
suitcase just grab one pair of bessies
nobody take you to the snow through the
rain through the cold times through the
warm times Bessie's has this dymatex
material that keeps your feet warm in
the winter and cool in the summer so
they work for every environment remember
when I said you could Splash around in
the swamp in Florida and your besties
that's because besties are a hundred
percent waterproof just rinse them off
and you're good to go if you're
splashing through the mud and just leave
them right outside your door and then
when you go back out they'll be
perfectly fine they're also vegan 100
cruelty free they even use less product
in the making of the shoe it's pretty
awesome so no matter if you personally
need a pair of traveling shoes or if you
need to get a family member a gift
Bessie's the perfect way to go because
they're having a huge Black Friday sale
so if you go to bessie.com quarter crew
go check out all the different shoes
that they have on sale but on top of
that the first hundred people to use the
code Sox quarter crew you get a free
pair of socks with your besties what's
better than that I personally lose socks
all the time but it's the first hundred
people a lot of you guys watch this
video so as soon as you see me talking
about it right now go to bessie.com
remember to put in the code socks
quarter crew so you can get a free pair
of socks with the shoes that you're
getting on sale I don't think there's
anything better going on this holiday
season in my opinion say yes eat a Vesti
and enjoy react
wow okay I'm sweating almost
that was amazing thank you so much Mark
for real like having your 26 years of
experience we barely even touched the
surface of what you've done in this
career and in this industry the stuff
that we spoke about I was watching as a
kid it inspired me the one to do this so
thank you again for being out here where
can we as a fan base show you love and
keep up with you it's really the only
platform I use is Instagram my Instagram
name is action Wags I like my last name
I do accept comments I do communicate
with people so always reach out to me on
there thanks for joining us mark
yes thank you so much peace